SCOTT HAALAND: In the
next couple minutes,
I'll demonstrate how
easy it is to leverage
existing Apigee APIs to
develop no-code applications.
We're going to start in the
Apigee environment, where
we have an open API
specification, an API
proxy that represents that
spec, and an API product, which
publishes the API proxy for
client applications to consume.
Today an app created in
AppSheet will be our client.
In our Hipster
Products API proxy,
we can see a pre-flow policy
that checks for an API key.
This helps to secure
the API, as only
apps that have this secret
key can invoke the API.
Next we can see the
API product that
publishes the API for
client applications
to use called Hipster Silver.
At the bottom of the
API product definition,
we can see that an app has
been registered already
for AppSheet.
And this is where we can
get the API key for our app.
Now we're going to
switch personas.
We've been an Apigee API
producer up until now.
In AppSheet, we will put on
the hat of Paul Parker, who's
a line-of-business user.
The first thing we'll do
is create a data source
to point to our API in Apigee.
We'll click on the Plus Data
Source to add a new one.
We'll name the data source
Apigee Hipsters Demo
and select the Apigee type.
We enter the API key
from Apigee and the URL
to the OpenAPI spec.
And now we can validate
and then authorize access
to create the data source.
Next, we create an app.
We'll go to the My Apps area.
AppSheet noticed that we
don't have any apps yet,
so it's assuming we
want to create one.
We do.
We'll use the Start From
Your Own Data option,
and the data will come
from our Apigee API.
We'll call this
app Hipsters App.
Now is when we get to choose the
Apigee data source we created.
I'll select Apigee
Hipsters Demo.
Let's select Product.
AppSheet just created
the app for us.
And we can see the preview
of the app in the right pane
already.
We just need to make
a few adjustments.
I know that there is a picture
of each product in the data,
and that's not showing up.
We'll change the
picture type to Image.
The product ID is kind of ugly.
Let's change the app
to not show that.
And then it will show
the product name first.
Let's save our changes.
Now the images are showing
up, and the product names
look great.
AppSheet helped us create our
first app within a minute.
Let's go to the Tablet
view so that you can see
a larger version of the app.
We can see that there's
also a Detail page created
for each of the products.
And we can navigate
from product to product
on the Detail screen.
Now let's go back
to the summary list.
Once I've adjusted the app to
be just how I want it to be,
I'll be able to deploy
it to mobile devices
and as a web app.
This was a quick overview of how
to leverage your existing APIs
to build no-code applications.
Are you ready to empower
your business users
with AppSheet and Apigee?